today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
for like a day i was thinking maybe
october would be a nice
quiet month but uh that is not panning
out donald trump left walter reed
medical center yesterday via helicopter
after
spending barely more than 48 hours there
in treatment for coronavirus he arrived
on saturday
sort of like midday i think it was about
noon or so on the east coast
leaving yesterday around 6 30 p.m
eastern time is he cured
no uh and in fact doctors
who who have um opined about this say
that
this is uh typically or frequently
a lull in the disease before it gets
much worse is he contagious
probably but he flew back to the white
house
and immediately removed his mask trump
in video captured with him standing on a
balcony at the white house
which we will look at a little bit later
visibly struggling to breathe
we which we're going to get to but the
really notable thing aside from having
no idea the state of donald trump's
health
in any sense whatsoever was a short
statement that donald trump recorded
just outside the white house upon his
arrival now i really need to give you
some setup to do this
with some context donald trump is on
dexamethasone
that's a steroid it can cause euphoria
mania delusions of grandeur
aggressiveness
all sorts of symptoms trump may have
more energy right now
and may feel better for the time being
all because of the medications that he
is on
and with that being said take a look at
this video that donald trump recorded
upon his return to the white house
i just left walter reed medical center
and it's really
something very special the doctors the
nurses the first responders
and i learned so much about coronavirus
and one thing that's for certain don't
let it
dominate you don't be afraid of it
you're going to beat it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines
all developed recently and you're going
to beat it i went
i didn't feel so good and two days ago i
could have left two days ago two days
ago i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago don't let it
dominate don't let it take over your
lives
don't let that happen so you can hear
that trump's voice is not
really there but what he's saying
is what i really want to focus on don't
be afraid
of coronavirus don't let coronavirus
dominate you
it's almost like he's saying it's a
personal
failing if coronavirus hits you hard
or kills you he decided he's not going
to let it dominate him
of course he has the best health care in
the world
despite not paying federal taxes but you
paying for
that service that he received through
your federal taxes
he decided not to let it dominate him a
very dangerous message
then he goes into kind of generic
nationalist nonsense
we have the greatest country in the
world we're going back we're going back
to work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led what does that
even mean
i don't know but i know that there's
certainly danger in donald trump saying
this there there's danger
in it but i had to do it he had to
engage in risky behavior
that got him sick or he had to go to
walter reed what does it mean that there
was danger but he had to do it he had to
keep holding
rallies with large crowds despite a
raging pandemic
i don't know what he's talking about and
trump making less and less sense in this
video as it goes on
he keeps going with it listen to this
next whopper
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
and now i'm better and maybe i'm immune
i don't know
i'm better now and maybe i'm immune i
don't know
we could do like an hour on that alone
maybe i'm immune i don't know now of
course
as a general idea
when one recovers from these types of
viruses
generally speaking there is immunity
at least to some degree at least for
some period of time
with this coronavirus there are still
questions about
for how long are you immune how strong
is that immunity is immunity different
if you've had a more serious case
or a less serious case is immunity
different if you had an
asymptomatic case versus a symptomatic
case
a lot of questions but why even bring
this up and trump
actually admits he doesn't know maybe
i'm immune
i don't know completely irresponsible in
every way
and then donald trump as he's been doing
frequently lately
just repeating himself again saying a
lot this is not a replay this is the end
of the video
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentarily
thank you very much and walter reed what
a group of people thank you very much
vaccines coming momentarily trump says
medical experts and public health
experts of course saying
for the average person vaccines are not
coming momentarily
trump really does not seem well here
he seems like he's barely hanging on
thanks to the medication
and the next few days it's really you
know the next
week or so is going to be very telling
trump really might be on the path to
kicking this
uh or he might get much worse as many do
after seven to ten days
which would put him at this weekend
there's actually
uh this will sound crazy to anybody who
thinks
critically and logically but there was a
trump uh adviser
yesterday who said trump plans to be at
the second debate which is
thursday next thursday what plans to
what does that even mean plans to be
all we can do is wait and see he also
very uh defiantly arrived at the white
house
and removed his mask and of course
right wingers fawning all over
themselves to say he's outdoors he's by
himself
but then he immediately turned around
and walked into the white house
and he is putting secret service in
danger
more employees at the white house have
tested positive
kaylee mckenney his press secretary has
tested positive
rudy giuliani did an interview on fox
news last night he couldn't stop
coughing we're going to get to all of
that later but
this is all stage managed
to show a triumphant defiant president
who has decided not to let the virus
dominate him
despite maybe being a super spreader
himself and
it is not it's not going to end well it
hasn't gone well
it already hasn't gone well given the
the amount of contagion not just
214 000 or whatever the number now is
dead in the united states a horrifyingly
high number uh
also the white house itself becoming one
of the primary hot spots in the united
states
you know this this is super interesting
the great investigative reporter gabriel
sherman
published a piece in vanity fair
yesterday which says
that although everybody around donald
trump is publicly talking about he's
doing so great he's leaving the hospital
he's powerful
he did it he did it all donald trump
jr reportedly recognizes that trump's
behavior is completely outrageous
and believes that they need to do an
intervention on his dad
uh gabriel sherman writing that
according to a source
he spoke to don jr is deeply upset by
donald trump's decision to do the corona
caravan
drive around walter reed on sunday
one of the sources said to gabriel
sherman don jr thinks trump is
acting crazy don jr told friends
that he went to ivanka and eric trump
and jared kushner and said we we have to
stop
dad from acting so unstable
and that he wants an intervention but
that
jared kushner and ivanka trump keep
telling trump you're doing great you're
just doing great you're killing it dad
don jr is said to be reluctant to
confront his father alone
saying quote i'm not going to be the
only one to tell him
he's acting crazy after donald trump on
monday morning sent out more than
what was it a dozen 15 20 all caps
tweets
the trump children did say to people
they would prefer
trump stop tweeting according to a
source close to the family quote
they're all worried they've tried to get
him to stop
tweeting as you know donald trump has
been prescribed medications
which medical experts agree can impair
cognitive function
affect mood euphoria mania delusions of
grandeur
and this is actually something i want to
talk to anthony scaramucci about
are people afraid of confronting trump
about anything does this explain why
he keeps saying the 1917 flu he keeps
saying plasma
instead of plasma and there's a super
interesting paragraph in the vanity fair
piece which says quote
there is a long history in the trump
family of denying serious illness
according to a trump family friend
trump's father fred trump senior
insisted on working
even after his alzheimer's disease
advanced in the 1990s to retire
is to expire fred senior would say the
friend said that as fred senior's
disease worsened
he once came down the stairs wearing
three neckties the family created a
system
so that fred could think he was still
running the trump organization every day
fred senior would go to his office in
brooklyn
they would give him blank papers to sort
through and sign
the phone on fred's desk was set up so
that it could only dial his secretary
fred pretended to work the family friend
said trump's hopped up on euphoria and
mania-inducing steroids and making very
poor decisions on a day-to-day basis
maybe something similar is going to be
put in place and case in point
in theory in principle trump can still
make decisions about not launching
nuclear weapons
we know that richard nixon when he was
under the influence
of drugs for at least part of his
presidency
there was a system where the defense
secretary told the military commanders
do not take richard nixon's orders
without somebody else in a senior
position endorsing it
has something similar been put in place
with donald trump we don't know
but even don jr who does not always seem
to be
having his wits about him himself very
often when we see him on video
even don jr recognizing some of what's
going on
wanting an intervention which from
everything we know is not going to
happen
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman we have
so much more to discuss today the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the number one way to
support our program
is uh very simple grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
up through election day you can take
advantage of the coupon code
2020 now 2020 now
no space all lowercase well numbers
can't be lowercase but you understand
uh grab a membership and you will also
get access to the daily
members only bonus show at
joinpakman.com
so donald trump left walter reed medical
center yesterday there's a real question
about the disease progression we don't
really know exactly what his health
status
is but we didn't need to wonder
too much when donald trump arrived back
at the white house
in a complete propaganda moment donald
trump defiantly stood
saluting and watching marine one the
helicopter
leave after depositing him back at the
white house donald trump removed his
mask and what i guess was supposed to be
framed as some kind of act of courage
despite it being
very very risky given that donald trump
by all accounts is still very contagious
and what was interesting about that
moment is that as donald trump stood and
watched marine one
leave you can tell that he is struggling
to breathe trump is gasping for
air and using his neck and upper chest
muscles to actually breathe
medical experts who watch this video
agree that that is indeed
what we are seeing here uh donald trump
at another moment
again after removing his mask of course
wincing in pain as he tries to breathe
this is a sign
of serious coronavirus still
affecting donald trump and bear in mind
that this is trump struggling to breathe
while on corticosteroids like
dexamethasone
typically reserved for patients in an
icu
with coronavirus on a ventilator with
coronavirus or having
such breathing issues that they are
expected or
projected to need that level of care
soon
that's who typically gets dexamethasone
donald trump getting it
we've gotten no clear explanation from
his doctor as to whether
this was indeed because donald trump is
that sick or because he's merely the
president and they're throwing
everything at him
but donald trump there wincing in pain
struggling to breathe
author mike jalit on twitter posted
some text messages he exchanged with a
cardiologist friend of his from a major
hospital
and what we are seeing is the same thing
that doctors are seeing trump visibly
struggling to breathe
the doctor actually says saw a brief
clip of his breathing
and it looks pretty bad watching a
longer stretch
now not good breathing the same doctor
later adding that if he does go back to
walter reed
his chance of survival becomes quite low
he will not go
unless he is in dire straits he is
basically getting hospital level care
in the white house now the doctor also
says trump can't get
icu care at the white house there is
speculation
that something close to an icu has been
set up at the white house medical unit
in the event that it becomes necessary
for donald trump
we just don't know because they lie all
the time
constantly about everything what we can
surmise
is trump probably is partially feeling
okay enough to start demanding a ride
around the block
and to start manic tweeting and to
demand to go back to the white house
partially he's feeling like he can do
that because he is on steroids that can
cause euphoria mania and delusions of
grandeur that's one piece of it
the other side is that the disease
can have a progression where once you
are seven to ten days in
there is a sort of second wave donald
trump reportedly
plans to be at the debate next
thursday is that possible well we just
won't know
until we get at least to this weekend at
which point many people
get much worse and deteriorate we really
don't know
trump's doctors are not being being
forthcoming and
we we are going to have to wait and see
what we need to get on the table now is
joe biden must be protected at all costs
joe biden had three negative coronavirus
tests since being
presumably exposed at the first debate
last tuesday
and if indeed donald trump plans to be
at next thursday's debate
joe biden has already said he will
consult
with his doctors and figure out what it
is that they advise him to do
i would not find it overboard to request
that biden be
20 30 feet away from donald trump bring
plexiglas
do whatever he has to do biden must be
kept safe from donald trump who has
effectively become a super spreader
okay this is big news i told you
yesterday
that today we would have new polling
that was done at least partially
after donald trump tested positive for
coronavirus
we have our first such pole and the
bottom
appears to have completely dropped out
for donald trump
in a new cnn poll joe biden is leading
donald trump
by 16 points 57 to 41
among likely voters some of the recent
big lead polls have been
registered voter polls likely voter
polls
this close to the election considered
more accurate
and indeed this is the worst poll
for trump of the entire campaign now to
be as
cautious as we can okay this poll has a
margin of error of 3.6
this means that the results could
be as close as an 8.8 point lead
if you account for the largest margin of
error
in the most favorable way possible to
trump imagine that joe biden's 57
is really only 53.4 imagine that trump's
41
is really 44.6 that gives us a margin
minimum of 8.8 and that is
basically where the national average now
is if you look at the national average
of recent polls
joe biden leads by an average of 9.2
points
now as a brief reminder before i get
into all of my caveats and
we've got to vote rant you know prepare
yourselves for that
um if we look back at 2016 on this day
october 6th on october 6 2016
hillary clinton's lead over donald trump
was 4.1
okay so today joe biden's lead over
trump
is 124 percent larger
than hillary's was on this days in 2016.
now
think back to yesterday if we looked at
october 5th
this year versus october 5th four years
ago uh
joe biden's lead yesterday was 107
percent bigger
than hillary's on this on that day in
2016.
we are now 24 hours later and thanks to
two new polls
joe biden's lead is now 124
larger than hillary's on this day in
2016. now what does this mean
i'll wait what does this mean you all
know
we have to vote this means nothing other
than we have to vote
plus 16 in october when the polls are
expected to tighten
it is stunning but we have to vote nate
silver from 538 in fact
issuing a word of caution tweeting this
morning about the new poll that quote
it's good that pollsters are publishing
these results instead of sitting on them
and this is one of those times when a
large movement in the race
is plausible but we have a lot of
polling at it most and i think it means
and it mostly suggests more modest gains
for joe biden we have the opportunity
to make a historic repudiation of donald
trump a reality
it's only an opportunity right now we're
going to talk
about states in which early voting has
started and is starting yesterday today
tomorrow
next monday we have the opportunity to
actually make this the biggest landslide
since reagan in the 80s or
we have the possibility of being utterly
devastated
that we are going to have another four
years of this
and we will know about that maybe
november 3rd very late maybe november
4th or 5th
let's actually make it happen and you
know what one of the great reasons to
make it happen is i want a stronger
economy
and one of the things we know is that
the economy does
far better when there's a democratic
president a new report
says exactly that and we're going to
talk about that next
we have a new report out from goldman
sachs
the report is shocking a lot of people
and i don't know why the report says
that if biden wins
and there is a blue wave in the senate
if there is a big picture blue wave led
by joe biden defeating donald trump
goldman sachs says
it would lead to a surge in economic
growth
and i see people acting oh my oh my
a democrat it would be good for the
economy be
i'm so shocked no if you've watched my
show
for a while you would already know why
democratic presidents are better for the
economy
goldman wrote in a note yesterday that
democratic control of the presidency and
of congress
would raise the probability of a fiscal
stimulus package worth at least 2
trillion dollars
but it's not just that longer term
spending measures that joe biden
wants like infrastructure climate health
care education
that boosts economic growth prospects
according to goldman sachs assuming that
the federal reserve
doesn't mess with interest rates until
we get back to full employment and
inflation just above two percent goldman
sachs estimates that quote
the net effect of the biden package
would be a front loaded
increase as well as a more backloaded
boost
to core pce inflation now
goldman is also being upfront that if
biden is
successful for example in raising the
corporate income tax rate
from 21 to 28 maybe that wouldn't be so
good for markets and for the economy
there's debate there but would that even
get passed it really depends on what
happens in the senate
now on the positive side goldman also
says
if we get a blue wave in november we
will likely have
easier u.s fiscal policy a renew a
reduced
risk of trade escalation and a
firmer global growth outlook we call it
stability when donald trump is gone
but none of this should surprise you
because the country does
better economically under democratic
presidents
i talked about this 15 years ago i
talked about it 10 years ago
i talked about it five years ago i
talked about it in june
this is not about whether democratic
presidents are left
enough or really progressive or what
this is merely about looking at a
totality of indicators
when you have a democratic president
versus a republican president
and it's better under democrats so why
would it be any different under joe
biden
let's look at those metrics typically we
would look at
gdp growth unemployment stock market
performance
then there's other you know intangibles
like respect around the world you can
look at poverty inflation different
elements
stock market average annualized return
when you have a democratic president is
14.3 percent
it is 10.8 percent under republicans the
stock market does about 40
better under democratic presidents but
that's not the economy
what about gdp gross domestic product
through 2008
real gdp grew faster under democratic
administrations than republican 4.1
versus 2.7 if you were to extend those
numbers to today
uh barack obama had better gdp numbers
than donald trump so it remains gdp
and stocks better with a democratic
president
what about income growth well under
democrats real median
income over the last 50 years grew at
2.2 percent per year
under republicans only 0.6 percent so
there you've got
wages on the flip side unemployment has
been
18 percent higher under republican
presidents
since world war ii job creation
democratic presidents have seen
24 million more jobs
created on their watch with an average
of
78 percent more jobs created per
year of a democratic administration than
during a republican administration
bloomberg looked at u.s job creation and
found
that for the close to half century
following the kennedy administration
democrats have created wait for it
nearly twice as many private sector jobs
as republicans
even though democrats have had the
presidency
for five fewer years during that time
none of this is new and none of this is
news
this is the reality and we see
republicans
maintain almost a monopoly
on the reputation of being good for the
economy
how many republican governors have
actually destroyed state budgets look at
what happened in kansas
but if you've been following the data
you would know
that this is merely a lie and even on
economy
trump's numbers are worse compared to
bidens than
most republicans again there's this idea
that republicans are better for the
economy they are not
when they say republicans are good for
the economy what they mean is
republicans will cut regulations and
it'll it'll allow companies to make
money by polluting
companies to make money by taking
advantage of the environment taking
advantage of employees
that lets the very rich get slightly
richer but it's not so good for the
economy overall
when republicans say we're good for the
economy because of small government
they mean we will cut education and we
will cut welfare
but we will keep writing blank checks to
the military budget
we'll pay farmers to grow nothing or to
destroy crops and we will continue this
failed idea of what it means to run an
economy it is all horrible code it's
immoral code for
really bad policies that help the very
rich
but aren't so good for everybody else
it's great that goldman sachs put out
this report
but it's not actually newsworthy because
if you've been paying attention
for the last however many years you
would know that this is a false
notion that republicans are great for
the economy we'll have some of the data
i mentioned
today on our instagram page okay so make
sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there follow me on instagram
for a break from politics it's puppies
books and what else i don't know a lot
of that
on my instagram david.pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
it is great to welcome to the program
today anthony scaramucci who is the
former white house communications
director one of
one of a few for the current president
uh also the founder
of sky bridge anthony i really
appreciate your time
it's good to be here david thank you for
having me so to start with
how did you first enter the universe of
donald trump
that that even led to you being in the
position of communications director
so i i just uh interviewed governor jeb
bush for my salt talk series and i
yelled at him
and told me see if you had won the
primary and gone on to the presidency i
wouldn't have been anywhere near the
white house and so
i'm your garden variety fundraiser i
happen to be hosting wall street week
for the fox business channel
in 2016. but i've been a lifelong
republican fundraiser i grew up in a
blue collar family so it was a way for
me to
reach a group of people that i would
have never had the opportunity to reach
through the networking of political
fundraising and so
uh i was working for jeb bush he dropped
out of the race looked like
then candidate trump was going to be the
nominee he called to recruit me
i went over to see him i had known him
from you know circles inside of new york
did i know him well know but i knew them
well enough where we had a wrong you
know
rapport with each other uh we had worked
together on the 2012
mitt romney campaign we had done some
fundraising for governor romney
and so i accepted the opportunity to go
work for him uh steven mnuchin and i
built out the architecture for his
fundraising
and then when he won i was originally
supposed to be his opl director but then
reince priebus and steve bannon didn't
want me in the white house so they
pulled sort of a washington two-step i
then called president trump and this is
one of the classic mistakes and it's a
good learning lesson for your
listeners don't put your pride in your
ego into your decision making because
when you do that your
uh intelligence goes uh down and your
emotions go up and so
i made that mistake i told president
trump those two guys were bad guys
if you need me to help you get rid of
them call me one day i'll come down and
fix it for you next thing you know i'm
the comms director
uh i make a mistake i say something off
color which was actually ridiculously
funny about steve bannon
i thought i was saying it to a friend it
turned out the guy was a treacherous guy
and he ran over to cnn with a recording
of it
i got fired and frankly i deserve to be
fired i shouldn't have put the president
or the administration in that situation
but here's the silver lining i got out
of the white house i went back and
rebuilt my business
i saved my marriage and i created a
terrific relationship with
general kelly the man that fired me so
uh when you're having
ups and downs in life just you got to
keep going as winston churchill said
when you're walking through hell keep
walking
so okay there's a bunch of things there
i wanted to touch base
about so one is you mentioned bannon
didn't want you
involved in the white house uh within if
i recall the timeline correctly
when you were announced as white house
comms director
sean spicer the timing of sean spicer
leaving seemed to coincide with that it
seemed he didn't want you involved as
well because of it
what what is it why is it that these
guys did not want you involved
well i would say in fairness to steve at
that point i think he was indifferent i
don't think he cared if i was involved
or not it was really white's priebus
reince priebus really didn't want
anybody
from new york that had a rapport with
president trump
to be involved so that would have
included chris christie and mayor
giuliani
as well as myself and other new yorkers
so uh
uh he had an unholy alliance it was an
unnatural alliance because these guys
really didn't like each other
but he had an unoi alliance with steve
bannon
and so that's why if you remember this
is going back three years ago now there
was tremendous leaking and
tremendous amounts of dysfunctionality
in the white house
and so the president in fairness to the
president he deserved a better staff
than that he deserved people that were
going to try to help him execute his
agenda
but then we learned about the president
that he's not really a great manager so
he can't keep
staff or he has a tendency to rotate
through the staff too quickly there's no
loyalties or allegiances and this is why
you have this
unbelievably dysfunctional situation
that's unfolded for
the united states over the last four
years what ultimately caused
donald trump to turn on you so publicly
because if i recall correctly for a
little while after you left
at least it didn't seem like you were
being antagonized by the president but
at some point something changed there
well i mean i would say not only not
antagonize i was very supportive i left
the white house i admitted that i made a
mistake i didn't blame anybody for my
firing other than myself and i was
trying to
maintain a level of support and loyalty
that the president the republican party
and his agenda
uh and but you know listen i'm running a
business i've got to be objective he's
separating women from children
uh and putting them in cages i'm sorry i
can't subscribe to that
he's disavowing our intelligence
agencies in helsinki
can't subscribe to that he's calling the
press the enemy of the people
i mean it's in the first amendment david
for a reason i can't subscribe to that i
actually wrote an op-ed
in april 2019 explaining why the press
is not the enemy of the people
but i think the peace day resistance for
me was the
uh he went after the four women in the
congress the
known as the squad uh some of them are
african-americans one is a muslim
american
one is a hispanic american he said that
they should go back to the countries
that they originally came from three of
them were born in the u.s
one was a naturalized citizen all four
were democratically elected to our
congress
that's a ridiculous racist nativist
trope
and frankly david uh they used to say
that to my italian-american grandparents
a hundred years ago to go back to the
country
that they originally came from and as i
told mayor giuliani i'm not going to
disavow
my personal integrity i'm not going to
disavow my family's
history in the united states by
supporting that kind of behavior so
i was on the bill more show i was trying
to defend him on the economy and some of
the
policies and deregulation i'm asked
about that i said no that's racism he
should not do that
so then he started to attack me that's
no problem i'm a big boy if you want to
attack me i'm a public figure i know how
to handle myself i attacked him back
i think i called him fidel ate off trump
i tried to get the fat shaming in there
you know
the notorious fat with the dictatorship
that he's trying to run he didn't like
that he hit me again so i hit him
and then he did what he classically does
because he's a complete low life he
starts going after my wife
and so listen my wife and i had personal
problems we almost got divorced as a
result of me working for him
i mean i mean she dislikes him she
probably doesn't dislike him as much as
melania trump dislikes him but i mean
she's up there
and so you know what what can i tell you
uh he goes after my wife i mean now
we're in a blood
now we're in a cage match yeah you know
i'm not ted cruz
uh i'm an italian kid from long island
uh you don't go after my wife
and so the fight started uh
and uh i don't want to see november the
third will be an interesting referendum
for the country and for mr trump we'll
have to see what happens but
i think he's going to get destroyed in
that election so help me understand
when you're although it was not a long
time but when you were in the role of
white house communications director from
the outside looking in
we see the constant lying from donald
trump and then we see people who are
brought in
who never will say it was a lie they
have to sort of clean it up we see it
with kaylee mcinanni
we've seen it with others what is going
on behind the scenes
in terms of are you all amongst
yourselves saying
this guy's lying how do we clean it up
or is there while people are in the role
you kind of put on a veneer where you
don't even admit to yourself that you're
defending lies
well i wasn't there long enough and i
only did one press conference and you
could go back and look at the press
conference i didn't
lie at all in the press conference no no
i mean and to clarify i mean
like observing what it's like when he's
constantly lying in public and people
have to clean it up
well well yeah i mean that's there's
great frustration related to that i mean
i was only there for 11 days but i can
tell you we're preparing a speech he
steps into the rose garden
it's actually a very good number form i
don't remember exactly what it was about
but the number
was uh 86 percent he goes into the rose
garden he says it's 90
comes back into the oval office so why
did you say it was
90 i mean 86 was a great number oh no i
said 90 90 is a better number
actually it actually isn't because now
you're gonna get four pinocchios on the
washington post and
it's going to add to this litany of lies
it doesn't it's not a good reflection on
you
you know you make it he doesn't get his
point is he's been lying in real estate
he's been lying in business he's been
lying to his wives he's been lying to
his children and
and so his point is i've gotten away
with this for so long
let me double and triple down on the lie
and if you
you know if you really study propaganda
you know what does joseph gerbel say
about the lie the bigger the lie
the more astounding it is the more you
can get people to believe it and so he's
got a group of willing acolytes
that will accept what he is saying even
though you can prove to them that it's a
lie
they'll accept what he's saying and so
for that
and so many other reasons he's got to go
and we're working super hard to make
that happen
so yesterday there was an article in
vanity fair by gabriel sherman
where it gabriel says that don jr in
particular
is very worried about the last 48 hours
worried about the corona caravan around
walter reed worried about the tweets and
that
he doesn't want to be the only one to go
in and confront donald trump and say
this has to stop
my question is are are people afraid of
those confrontations because when
you hear trump say the 1917 flu for six
months it's like does nobody go in and
say it's 1918. when he says
plasma instead of plasma for six months
is that because people are afraid to go
in and say
you know mr president you're saying this
wrong this is not right
well i mean you know they may say it to
him he'll either ignore it or they may
just not say it to him because they
don't want to get fired you know
what he's done in october of 2019
someone came to my office at skybridge a
senior cabinet official a recognizable
name globally
sat on my couch and said hey you know
this is going to be really bad i said
well why is that well you know he can't
manage anything
and he's got everybody inside the
executive branch
fearing that they're going to be
humiliated on twitter or he's going to
fire them in this public display of
humiliation
and so they're not doing anything
they're all holding back and they're not
coordinating with each other and so you
need treasury sometimes to help justice
and
justice sometimes to help the department
of homeland security or the pentagon
to help state and everybody's frozen
there's no mechanisms inside the white
house
or at the cabinet level that's creating
a symphony of communication among these
departments and cabinet agents
sub-agencies and so forth and so
if there is a crisis we will be
immobilized at the top of the government
we won't be able to handle the crisis i
actually thought the crisis was the
solemnity strike when that happened in
january which now seems like a thousand
years ago
i was looking at that thinking of what
that senior cabinet official said to me
in my office i said oh my god
this is going to be it thankfully cooler
has prevailed there
but it turned out the real crisis was
coveted 19 he
was not capable of handling it he lives
in this reality distortion field
he's trying to force the people around
him to live in that distortion field
which is why
so many good people have left the
administration or been fired by him
because they won't
abide by his nonsense and so he's now
he's now there with a group of spineless
sycophants inside the white house
and he's lying through his teeth he lied
about the science he lied about mass
wearing he couldn't coordinate a
unified strategy with the states to
bring down the virus and so the great
irony is
the economy which was the cornerstone of
his re-election campaign because of his
malfeasance and his malpractice
and his poor decision-making he
destroyed the economy and so
we're sitting here right now we've got a
guy who's incompetent
we have a guy that is uh
overcompensating for something
uh we got a guy that looked like he was
in a satire it was almost like a sacha
baron cohen satire comedy yesterday
of an eastern european dictator trying
to create a propaganda film
and that's where we are right now in
america but you know cnn's saying
5741 joe biden wall street journal
nbc saying 54 you know 42 joe biden
uh maybe those polls are over sample for
democrats i don't know i don't trust the
polling uh any more than anybody should
trust the polling we have to run through
the tape here and beat him on election
day so hopefully we'll do that
i think the good news i'm sorry go ahead
well he's the just the last statement
the good news for the american people
he's the polarizing candidate this time
people will go out and vote against him
my entire interview with anthony
scaramucci white house communications
director for a brief period of time
under donald trump and founder of
skybridge will be on the youtube channel
in full youtube.com slash the david
pakman show
on the podcast tv and radio show we'll
go to a quick break and be back right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so another person who might or might not
have coronavirus
thanks to a super spreader donald trump
is his sort of sometimes lawyer rudy
giuliani i genuinely don't know if rudy
giuliani is still donald trump's lawyer
what i do know is rudy did an interview
on fox news last night
and he just couldn't stop coughing
throughout and he's insisting he's still
waiting on a coronavirus test that a few
days ago he had a negative coronavirus
test
you have to see this not only can rudy
not stop coughing he's
sweaty throughout the entire interview
his eyes are half closed but that's
common for rudy in these later afternoon
or early
evening interviews for reasons we've
previously discussed it may or may not
be related to whatever rudy is fighting
off here
listen to this first video this does not
sound good
everybody questions the polls but pretty
consistently
um everybody questions the polls but
pretty consistently
um i i almost feel like i need to to
wear a mask just watching this
here's another one the scientists say
it's okay
he is going to scientists say it's okay
he is going to the scientists say it's
okay
he is going to and then here's a third
one you can actually see
fox anchor martha mccallum sort of
grimace
when rudy giuliani coughs i think they
both
uh realize that they accomplished more
that way
but the reality is when i hear that
response
that jones is going to listen to experts
and be guided and be
determined and the president is going to
do it i mean i was the mayor
so again um people being sick is
is not funny uh the fact that donald
trump himself
and everybody around him seems to be at
particular risk because of the behavior
they've chosen to engage in and
ridiculing masks and all of it
it's certainly ironic but it's never
funny when people are sick
it wasn't just the coughing by the way
that was notable it was also what rudy
giuliani said
here's a very horse-sounding giuliani
saying that trump really has learned a
lot from having coronavirus
that you're talking about where it
becomes you know maybe ridiculous like
driving by yourself in a car with one on
but do you think that this this whole
experience for the president will change
the way he looks at it a little bit
sure things like this do change you i
think he indicated that
that he's been educated a lot i think we
have to wait and see exactly
the conclusions that he's drawn from it
but i know he's drawn some conclusions
from what what he's what he's gone
through
and there's a balance here to be struck
between wearing a mask
and wearing a mask to the point of
almost you know a political theater or
or maybe even worse than that fear on
irrational fear
why does trump have to get covid to
learn about it and change his view it's
sort of like when the
end why does an anti-gay republican only
realize that their policy has hurt
people
when their kid comes out as gay or their
niece
comes out as bisexual or whatever the
case may be why can't they empathize why
aren't they capable of abstract thought
everything is only
i got it oh it's serious now here is
rudy giuliani
on some aimless rant about doctors
versus scientists and doctors aren't
scientists and it's all
just really really weird what would you
say to joe biden there
well i would say to joe that you don't
really understand what scientists are
first of all listen to your doctors
that's for sure they know your personal
history
doctors really aren't scientists when
they're scientists uh
almost always have competing opinions
that's what science is about
science isn't a didactic dogmatic
religion
there's almost almost every principle of
this kind of science
you know medical science has uh
conflicting opinions
and for example
it isn't science to be wearing that mask
joe
when you're giving a speech and the
people are 30 or 40 feet away from you
the only thing you can effect when you
uh
when you're doing that is a teleprompter
that's closer to you
so i i see through you who is this
interview even targeted at
right i mean when you think of like who
are they try what is the point of
sending rudy giuliani out
at this point particularly coughing like
this why would you go and do an
interview
with such a terrible cough waiting for a
coronavirus test
when the president has coronavirus it's
maybe i don't understand the psyche of
the trumpest
of the fox news viewer maybe i don't
understand the propaganda value of
sending rudy giuliani out there anyway
coughing is the
are trump is going to see this and say
wow what a
strong giuliani even with the cough even
maybe with coronavirus if that's what it
is he has
he's still going and doing tv interviews
it like
are are they that deluded that they
would not think about the fact that
trump is spreading this like wildfire to
people around him
that rudy if indeed he has coronavirus
is contagious and he's at a studio
it seems maybe that's a home studio i
don't know but it seems like a studio
it would that not computer let me know
what you think
cancel you know stay home send somebody
else it's absolutely vile
the latest in the conga line of
coronavirus infections
connected to the white house is donald
trump's own press secretary kaylee
mckennany
we just saw a video of rudy giuliani
unable to stop
coughing during a fox news interview he
is waiting on his latest test results
for coronavirus
we may have gotten those results by the
time you watch that clip or this clip
but someone who did test positive is
white house press secretary
kelly mcinanny and two of her deputies
have tested positive for the coronavirus
as well
as donald trump has now left walter reed
medical center
presumably still contagious first lady
melania trump
remains in isolation with coronavirus
she reportedly doesn't want to spread it
to the secret service agents who she
would be exposing if she were to try to
go
anywhere kaylee mcinanni putting out a
statement
via twitter which says quote after
testing negative
consistently including every day since
thursday it's funny how they always say
that like
listen everybody who gets coronavirus
tests
would have tested negative for a long
time until they test positive okay
after testing negative consistently
including every day since thursday
i tested positive for covid19 on monday
morning
while experiencing no symptoms no
reporters producers or members of the
press are listed as close contacts
by the white house medical unit moreover
i definitely
i definitively had no knowledge of hope
hicks's diagnosis prior to holding a
white house press briefing on thursday
as an essential worker i have worked
diligently to provide
needed information to the american
people at this time
that's funny the idea that her lies are
essential
with my recent positive tests i will
begin the quarantine
process and will continue working on
behalf
of the american people remotely now this
is a picture of her just days ago
briefing
a gaggle of reporters without a mask on
and it simply
continues to spread at the white house
she was criticized for briefing
reporters
without a mask hours after donald trump
tested positive
the defenders came out and said they
were socially distant she was she took
the mask
off only when she was uh not near
reporters well for the entire week
during which she was likely contagious
or part of that week
she wasn't wearing a mask at all the
mask started
later on in the week we of course have
numerous others connected to trump who
have tested positive at this point it's
hard to even keep track but it includes
trump's own campaign manager bill
stephen republican national committee
chairwoman
rana mcdaniel trump advisor kellyanne
conway and kellyanne conway's daughter
claudia conway have tested positive
new jersey governor chris christie
tested positive three republican
senators i mentioned yesterday mike lee
of utah
tom tillis of north carolina who's up
against it he may be about to get
beaten badly by cal cunningham in north
carolina
uh wisconsin republican ron johnson nick
luna who's a personal assistant to
donald trump
the university of notre dame president
john jenkins tested positive he was at
the amy coney barrett event
not this past saturday but the previous
one at the white house which does appear
to be
a super spreader event at least three
journalists who were at the white house
over the last week have now tested
positive according to the
white house correspondents association
remember when kaylee mcinanny
said on fox news back in february
the following absolutely this president
will always put america first he will
always protect american citizens we will
not see diseases like the coronavirus
come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing when contrasting
it
with the awful presidency of president
obama kaylee mcadamie thank you so much
good to see you thank you so that was a
ridiculous thing to say
then and it's even more ridiculous to
say it now
that donald trump has it and she now has
tested positive
it is the fascinatingly dystopian
secondary story so you've got how has
this administration handled coronavirus
that's a primary story it's immoral
it's disgusting and it's infuriating how
they handle it when
they themselves get the virus is
arguably more absurd
although not connected to as many deaths
because remember that this either began
or was exacerbated by a party in the
rose garden
as well as inside the white house where
hundreds of people sat
shoulder to shoulder without masks
hugging talking inches from each other's
faces
kaylee along with numerous other people
like william barr
have continued to make public
appearances with no masks
knowing they were exposed to people that
tested positive no contact tracing has
been done
we learned that joe biden's campaign was
not contacted as people started testing
positive including trump to say hey
this happened isolate test quarantine
whatever you need to do
they've been deceptive about the
timelines it has been asked now
nearly a dozen times when did donald
trump last test negative
they won't tell us directly implying
that trump either knew or suspected he
was contagious during the debate with
joe biden
that their claim on the honor system
that biden
rather that trump tested negative on the
day of the debate he probably wasn't
tested at all
and so aside from never doing that crazy
amy coney barrett event at the white
house
everybody here involved should have
immediately self-isolated for 14 days
when hope hicks got sick
that alone would have reduced the
transmission but they either don't care
or are unwilling to do the right thing
for other people it is stunning
they deserve a historic loss in november
not only
for their personal irresponsibility as
leaders but because they've overseen
one of the worst responses in the world
to the virus which is now surging again
in many states we have a voicemail
number which you can call
anytime that number is 2192 david p
here's a good question about trump's
treatment regimen
for coronavirus take a listen to this
hey
david this is dave from california
and we've all seen the medication that
trump is taking
don't you think it's surprising none of
the reporters asked
didn't ask that doctor why
hydroxychloroquine
was not on the list of medication
that's the medicine trump has been
telling forever
wanted everybody to take it
i just find that quite odd nobody not
even a reporter asked that question
so it was actually asked yesterday
yesterday in the in the briefing that
donald trump's dr sean connelly gave
before trump left walter reed he was
asked why didn't trump take
hydroxychloroquine given how much he's
been touting it it would be natural for
him to take it you would think
uh sean connelly said we discussed a lot
of things
but i'm not going to go into why he did
or didn't take anything in particular
we're just going to focus on what he did
take of course the the answer is
because it wouldn't work it doesn't work
it's been debunked that's why they
didn't give it to donald trump
and this is again more uh supporting
evidence that what they say publicly
is just optics and posturing and
politics it's not fact
it's not reality we have a great bonus
show planned for you today
we will talk about new zealand handling
a very small second wave of coronavirus
continuing to do really well
we will talk about how speaking two
languages appears to protect
against dementia and cognitive decline
very interesting new study we will also
talk about the arrest of
antivirus dude john mcafee
who has now been arrested in spain on
tax evasion
charges all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show
get the bonus show my friends get the
bonus show sign up for a membership at
joinpacman.com
and you will be given instant access to
the world
famous bonus show i will see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video